[Music]
can you believe that there there were
these parents in the UK that got sick of
their kid playing Grand Theft Auto why
video games
that's awesome Jo just fed up they were
like you know what eleven-year-old kid
get a [ __ ] in the car no drive your own
bar down the [ __ ] in the core joy thanks
boys Australian no can you tell the
difference between the Scottish is and
the Liverpool's yeah but then the
accents are different you're Irish so
like what is the difference sounds like
a Lucky Charms the Irish thank you
well I came out of your mouth so as I
try to uh crack Magura sounds like a
leprechaun England yeah I'm gonna beat
them
oh you'll see Scottish yeah come here's
a loser he's like a groundskeeper okay
all the things you say wanna hear it let
me tell you it sounds like Shawn listen
did you know that Irish people speak
their own language we mean yeah when I
was in Ireland for layover there were
speaking Irish he doesn't give a [ __ ]
what you just said the label did he spit
out we called it Irish what I love about
Cara's accent though is that it's more
attitude than anything else it's very
leery
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
it's they're correlated people talking
funny at the end of day we're talking
about people talking about I got it
people [ __ ] talk I feel disrespected
what happened she just said it I said it
you get it like winners come home and
[ __ ] the prom queen yeah that's a good
Connery come lips my eyebrow nailed it
is he older than old now he believe he's
still alive do the bond Connery Oh
bought James Bond I'd like a home I'd
like a martini
that's the grandpa bond that is old way
it's old power welcome yeah he wasn't
that that it was not his fun I know
anyway so we're talking about these
parents these bad parents well they did
mention like the police they tweeted out
that the driver of this car was 11 years
old
parenthesis yes 11 a family member was
fed up with the child playing Grand
Theft Auto all day on the PlayStation so
brought him out to practice driving on a
car park take him to a strip club - and
[ __ ] beat up a ha so they got sick
him playing games so they took him in a
real car so they couldn't just [ __ ]
unplug the thing and be like hey this
[ __ ] is grounded or you're grounded I'm
putting it away yeah maybe then he was
like an expert because of grand theft
auto this car I don't know is it that
bad at each a kid at 11 how to drive
yeah because I learned in the parking
lot around that age well isn't it bad
though because then the kid thinks I can
drive but maybe this kid is I mean I
guess like legally speaking it it is
wrong but I was also very young when I
was behind the wheel Sean Connery are
you do it again 3 it sounds like gaming
back in my day back in my day father was
in the room teaching me how to beat up a
hooker beat up a hooker
it's too much lip and Marjane you didn't
beat up a hooker in a video game
well there's kids have like race
go-karts and [ __ ] they're probably
really good already [ __ ] Jeep thing
right now
he's like drives like he goes in Reverse
like this what he backed up and he looks
behind him like that Wow
yes what correct so I mean I don't see
anything but he also drives away the
leaf around the crashes into bushes yeah
that's better well he is - have you guys
played Grand Theft Auto online a long
time
god damn sick is what it is oh my god
I'm waiting two years because I you know
you just hit a brick wall and you're
like I'm never gonna be productive again
if I keep doing this
yeah but I miss my cars I miss my cars
I miss my apartment I miss my DeLorean
frankly yeah a DeLorean
we had a DeLorean - but it was an
aggressive daughter was rocket League
what the DeLorean and it it couldn't
really fly it and I heard that they can
fly well I heard it got way better than
all the updates and [ __ ] and there's the
casino - now you can actually go into
the casino oh my god something I want to
start playing games let's get the final
five five it's not for a long time
doesn't matter that's awesome you
believe PlayStation 2 has turned twenty
years Wow
she blew my mind I was like what you
must be talking about the first place
honey is that the black one
what's the old that's the most resist
what you are we and how come nothing new
came out in console 20 years
Oh PlayStation 4 bro how do you not know
this [ __ ] ever sinned even on the pop
culture I didn't know they're about to
do the PS 5 they just announced yeah oh
[ __ ] I don't know where next box man I
just saw the [ __ ] Nintendo I what is
it the switch
yeah where we played that restaurant
game which is fun overcooked Nintendo
switch why were you in a Nintendo switch
I wonder if I could go back on my GTA
account and see my girlfriend I remember
that you
lost like two weeks out of your life
when you got you oh I [ __ ] finish
that [ __ ] like Joe Jake Hayes crumbling
I had a crew - it was me can and some of
his buddies and we were [ __ ] do
missions all day oh dude when the cowboy
game came out people lose my [ __ ]
life - cowboy red blood red
oh right there we gots what dude I got
bored of it in three days what you not
finish it
thank God I wouldn't have [ __ ] done
anything since other stories I didn't
even I was never sucked into the story
that much I heard it's great a lot of
people loved it fine I just never got
that into it Red Dead Redemption
oh gee Red Dead there's the plate number
I played I played the first one yeah I'm
not good at anything what kind of games
do you like you don't need to be good at
it it's so [ __ ] easy that guitar it's
the fun thing about these games is
you're living you're going through a
movie can you introduce me to one and
just that all just you know something
fallout 3 I don't know I never got that
many then I played that I played that
Skyrim I played that you play at
Skyrim's Tim no I don't I just said I'm
sorry no cuz I want to play all these
games cuz I miss it yeah and then I look
at my bank account and I'm all like you
got to be productive dude I get to
borrow you're right I don't
Ward that's my problem what do you get
you get bored playing the game yeah I
guess so nothing I got a story that
sucks me the [ __ ] I get bored you
know what I go back to my college days
because when I start playing games I
just stay home eat food jackoff stay put
stay on the play games that's all I do
back and forth and you were making money
I really did but I passed my [ __ ] though
did you graduate
oh yeah and by the way not observant to
people right now or listening this ball
playing a video game
I know you're out there ton of oh yeah
that's a very popular thing right now
they they play games while they listen
to things which is cool it's all good I
just
is this story sucks me the [ __ ] I can
do bar just saw this bed that they made
yeah a gamer ban gamer bed think I need
this
they [ __ ] they like god they got this
you don't mix right here the recline
dual screen like you wake up and there's
dual screens right here that's watched
that movie you know the Avatar one where
he gets sucked into that other world and
in that life becomes more fun than his
actual life no the movie the we don't
even have legs in real life was that how
the story was it was more fun than is
regularly paralyzed realizing you could
walk when he wasn't launched he's
paralyzed from the waist down from the
waist down but that was real if you want
to look at it object like it's not it's
not it's not like that but I'm saying
that is I don't watch that goddamn movie
I heard was really good all I'm saying
is that the game sucks you into the
point where it might be a little bit
better than real life oh I feel like
that's where all that tech is going well
we're gonna do that [ __ ] [ __ ]
simulation that we're in right now like
apparently we don't have the world that
we live in right now and we're just
playing as our I'm saying real life with
the simulations that you're saying you
say this is simulation right now I think
it might be I refuse it's gonna [ __ ] me
the [ __ ] up is kind of a relief to know
that it's all a simulation in that we're
all like it's a [ __ ] waste of time
hey geo if you wanted to go the speed of
light right now yes you would stop just
short of go in speed light and
everything around you would move very
slowly and almost stop because there are
rules in our universe why are there
rules because the simulation it's
goddamn coded and there's a certain
amount of bandwidth and how do you it so
then what happens that with this
knowledge are you just like oh man have
this
see on the game that we're all in and
win that's all what are you supposed to
win what's it have fun and jackoff a lot
no you said humor most games you're
supposed to collect as much treasure as
you [ __ ] can
treasure though is it is a treasure
objective yeah it's like points well in
this game it's money yeah today's day
today's day get as much money as you can
back to us all okay so at what time are
we out of the simulation like when we're
like [ __ ]
so it's a constant summation yeah like
you with your dream with my dream where
I'm like I felt like I was in another
like universe is that me out of the
simulation [ __ ] me up already it's
[ __ ] impression if we're not in a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
will not be a situation some intelligent
[ __ ] being created all of this so we
could [ __ ] around like this I think so
telogen beings are programming us like
we're [ __ ] with in aliens so jump off
this roof then no don't
or do you win the game when the game
that's a loose well I like my other one
where I have like infinite potential and
there is no no I'm on your side okay win
the game a [ __ ] game you want to fly
you can fly in this game you hit the
plane and fly maybe she has limited
bandwidth yeah I think so maybe yeah and
then coronavirus is like the next level
you just got to survive this I missed it
what happened I don't know that's a fun
part of the game coronavirus give me two
Coronas Oh
[Music]
[Music]